holy [ __ ] a bit of disclosure here full
disclosure I've had some rum and coke
and the movie is not being a good time
spoiler alert the dock yeah
and it's between me and you you you're
smiled you are so sad say ask your
professional on with the review so the
darkness is written my God knows who
directed by God knows what stars Kevin
Bacon he has a family and they're in
this house and I first are on vacation
in the Grand Canyon and the little kid a
ghost gravitate towards him and they go
back home and now is it's basically a
cliched haunting movie by cliche I mean
[ __ ] cliche everything you've ever
seen and Bulger Geist is in here
everything you've ever seen and another
haunting movies in this movie don't come
you're looking for new content cuz
you're not gonna find it best-case
scenario you can find content that's
been used before done better no guess
what it's not done better it's just a
bummer because that first there in the
middle of nowhere you're like all these
ghosts and shadows gonna terrorize this
family in the middle of nowhere that's
really cool it could be new out nope
they're back at their house and now it's
just basically the best it can be is a
cliche haunting movie that you've seen a
hundred times before well first of all
Kevin Bacon and everyone in the movie
they all did a fine job in the movie the
character development moments to have in
this movie are fine until they go
nowhere really the character development
moments in this movie are like coldest
acts like oh look at this straight he
got nope it goes nowhere alright going
back out example the daughter has an
eating disorder so it shows her being
bulimic she's throwing up her food it's
this whole huge thing then her and Kevin
Bacon are in a waiting room with the
doctor or a therapist or whoever they're
there to see guess what happens after
that nothing nothing pertaining to that
that really went nowhere it's almost
like there was no reason to have it in
the movie and everyone has that which is
a bummer because when you see
development moments like that you're
like hey this is gonna be a good movie
it's gonna be a ghost story but it's
gonna have guts it's gonna have depth
with the characters no weirdest thing is
you find out this ghost entity is
actually a few different entities that
are haunting this house in which case
who is I think it's Jenni's a girl's
name I think I remember if I remember
right it's Jenny
who the [ __ ] is that the kid keeps
talking about this ghost
friend but there's no ghosts at that
there's no Jenny there's no one ghosts
you never find out actually you never
find out any of the ghost names so why
do that who is that who's with the kid
who's his friend maybe jenny was like
nice maybe Jenny was a nice ghost that
was trying to help them against the
haunting and then got killed by the
other five or six or seven ghosts so
talent they have in this movie they're
actually talented actors that are used
like they could have used nobody it's
really a bummer they spent the money to
have Kevin Bacon this may be because
they could have had George working at
California Pizza Kitchen hoping for his
big breakthrough play the lead role in
this movie and he would have done just
as fine I guess I don't know how else to
explain it to you guys basically in the
end the darkness is nothing you haven't
seen before with performances that don't
really blow your socks off it basically
the movie sets up to promise that this
movie is going to be more than just your
basic cliched haunting movie then then
becomes your basic cliche haunting movie
there's an autistic kid because you know
hey why not with other arcs with the
characters that really lead no I'm
telling you guys I mean you walk out of
this movie even the end of the movie the
movie ends and it's like oh goes Santana
and all right I guess the movie's over I
guess that's just alright let's go to
our car because we're leaving the
theater now by speaking from personal
experience I'm just saying this movie's
not good enough to remember and I'm just
saying the darkness you're not going to
remember that movie in t-minus one day
ya already forgot don't waste your time
don't waste your money don't waste your
breath don't waste your energy alright
guys so the darkness you haven't seen it
don't stop lying to me you haven't seen
it at all you're never gonna see this
movie so what's your favorite haunting
movie of all time whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more